[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir je m'appelle noémie de lattre
je suis française je le précise parce
que je vais beaucoup vous parler de ma
langue ce soir et je suis actrice
voilà bon alors en fait je suis aussi
aux tris et metteuse en scène mais j'ai
pas pu l'écrire
ben non mon correcteur orthographique
refuse il le souligner en rouge si si
voilà enfin n'ont d'ailleurs pas tout à
fait honnête il a commencé par me
proposait en remplacement autruches et
monteuse en scène à nouveau je vous jure
que c'est vrai vraiment noémie de lattre
autruches et menteuse en scène j'adore
ma vie non mais c'est fou quand même
et alors comme j'ai eu l'outrecuidance
d'insister non pardon je ne suis ni une
autruche d'une menteuse
eh bien il me l'a souligné en rouge avec
mépris comme pour bien me signifier que
je ne serai jamais légitime dans ces
beaux métiers d'hommes et oui parce que
c'est pas évident d'être quelque chose
qu'on ne peut même pas nommé voyez ça ça
n'aide pas on va vous me direz c'est pas
grave j'ai quand même réussi à en faire
mon métier c'est le principal j'ai
réussi à vaincre la machine
je suis une 20 15
vingt quand vaincre s ah tiens c'est
marrant et vient aucun de ces monnaies
accepté par mon correcteur d'accord donc
en français vainqueur n'existe pas au
féminin ben merde ça prédestine un peu à
l'échec quand même non enfin je sais pas
c'est comme le masculin l'emportent sur
le féminin non mais cette règle de
grammaire qu'on rabâche à tous les
enfants de france depuis des décennies
le masculin l'emporté sur le féminin pas
c'est pas rien quand même
je veux dire quand on prête attention à
cette expression d'un mois quand j'étais
petite fille et qu'on me répétait sa ce
que j'entendais moi c'est ma chérie le
masculin est plus fort que toi il a le
pouvoir sur toi il a le droit de temps
porter est a perdu d'avancé
bah c'est pas les conditions optimales
pour s'épanouir et c'est valable dans
toutes les langues mais ce qui est
vraiment crucial c'est pas ça c'est que
la plupart d'entre nous pensent que bah
oui c'est comme ça que veux tu la langue
a été construite comme ça on n'y peut
rien on dit un tabouret une chaise un
point c'est tout qu'est-ce que tu vas
chercher
sauf que pas du tout les particularités
grammaticales que je viens de vous citer
ne doivent rien au hasard
elles doivent tous au sexisme si le
masculin l'emporté sur le féminin en
français c'est pas comme ça non c'est
parce que de gros machos phallocrate en
ont pris la décision au xviie siècle au
motif que le genre masculin est réputé
plus noble que le féminin parce que le
mal est supérieure à la femelle bien sûr
un pub donc ici le la langue reflète le
sexisme de l'époque élan racines ce qui
nous donne quand même droit à des
phrases du type 100 femmes sont belles
mais sans femmes et un caniche sont
beaux
voilà ce qui personnellement me fait un
petit peu mal aux seins et si je ne peux
pas nommer mon métier aujourd'hui c'est
pas parce que le mot n'existe pas et
qu'on refuse de l'inventer non c'est
parce qu'il a été délibérément supprimer
des dictionnaires au xviiie siècle ainsi
que écrivaine et auteur d'ailleurs au
motif que ce sont des féminins qui
écorche absolument les oreilles donc
évidemment non un la vérité n'a rien à
voir avec la sonorité des mots ça se
saurait si les langues se construisait
pour faire joli non évidemment
la vraie raison à la suppression des
féminins de métiers d'art de pensée de
pouvoir ou de politique sait que la
possibilité de l'émancipation des femmes
faisait tellement flipper les mecs qu'au
moment où elles ont commencé à demander
le droit de vote à la révolution
les françaises ils sont dignes info
réagir là manquerait plus qu après avoir
perdu un oeil sur les barricades
elle accède aux droits de vote ça serait
quand même un petit peu trop facile ici
le sexisme créé la langue pour
l'enraciner est la preuve que tout ceci
ne doit rien au hasard mais bien une
volonté d'entraver les femmes c'est que
les féminins comme boulangère ou
couturière qui ne représente pas une
menace imminente pour l'ordre établi et
le patriarcat ont été acceptés sans
problème oui oui crémiers crémière
boucher bouchehr éclatez vous les filles
et pas de problème tranquille en
revanche on a méticuleusement éradiquer
de tous les dictionnaires les féminins
de métier ou de fonctions pouvant être
des outils d'émancipation ainsi poétesse
et philosophe s par exemple sont passés
à la trappe
alors attention hein qu'on ne me parle
pas de sonorités parce que duchesse et
comtesses des meufs en robe à la solde
de leurs maris ça n'a gêné personne et
là où c'est vraiment fantastique
c'est que directeur d'école a donné
directrice d'école m décorées la 2d
maîtresse d'école
personne n'y a rien trouvé à redire en
revanche aujourd'hui encore en france on
n'a pas le droit de dire ça n'est pas
accepté par l'académie française
on n'a pas le droit de dire mais tu
restes
conférence directrice de recherche ou
directrice de thèse
c'est marrant et je ne parle pas des
métiers comme médecins avocats ou
professeurs qui n'existent carrément pas
au féminin en gros temps que tu
t'adresses à des enfants pour un salaire
de misère
y'a pas de problème mais si tu veux
adresser à des adultes experts pour une
somme un petit peu plus rondelette
il en est hors de question donc ce que
je veux dire c'est que quand on a
récemment je sais pas si vous avez suivi
cette actualité en france mais on a
récemment remercié l'académie française
de ne pas s'être opposé à la
féminisation des titres et métiers comme
s'il s'agissait de transformer la langue
à cause de quelques harpie hystérique
sous les fesses ou un effet de mode
j'ai un petit peu ricaner voilà parce
qu'on voit bien qu'il ne s'agit en aucun
cas de féminiser la langue mais juste de
la dea masculiniser voilà la langue
française comme bien d'autres n'est pas
sexiste par hasard elle est sexiste par
choix sexiste que nous subissons encore
aujourd'hui car il est évident qu'il y
ait un lien entre le fait qu'on ne
puisse pas trouver le mot chirurgienne
dans le direct dans le dictionnaire de
l'académie et le fait que tous aient
tout comme ça spontanément par défaut
sans réfléchir pensant que c'est naturel
on va dire bah tiens un chirurgien une
infirmière un président une secrétaire
un directeur une assistante un séducteur
une [ __ ]
hélas oui alors il ya quand même des
perspectives un petit peu plus brillante
que d'autres un voile a tenté si bien
qu'on a fini par admettre que tout ce
qui était du ressort du masculin étaient
positifs et tout ce qui était du ressort
du féminin était négatif masculin
féminin c'est bien ça craint grand petit
forts faibles joué comme un homme joué
comme une femme
et c est là où c'est merveilleux c'est
que bien sûr si une femme joue bien on
dira d'elle que c'est un garçon manqué
et si un homme joue mal on dira d'elle
on dira de lui que c'est une gonzesse ou
un [ __ ] bien sûr et ça pour le coup
c'est universel
quatre coins du globe alors j'ai un
petit exemple assez marrant en allemand
si vous voulez où il ya en opposition
deux adjectifs d'un côté d'amélie qui
vient de dam dam et qui veut dire
abrutis idiot imbéciles bon bah déjà
merci ça fait plaisir
voilà et surtout qu'en face on aère
l'équivalent d'un verre
monsieur et qui veut dire magnifique
brillant génial est-ce que c'est pas
formidable et alors là où on touche
carrément au miracle c'est dans les cas
où on peut utiliser aussi bien le
féminin que le masculin et où ça change
de sens en fonction du genre ça j'adore
ses mets préférés exemple un entraîneur
une entraîneuse le premier étant un
coach sportif et la deuxième une [ __ ]
voilà courtisans courtisane le premier
étant un proche du roi et la deuxième
une [ __ ] péripatéticien péripatéticienne
le premier étant un philosophe disciple
d'aristote et la deuxième
merci voilà put d'ailleurs petite
parenthèse qui est un nom merveilleux
parce que c'est vraiment un mot magique
je sais pas si vous avez remarqué mais
quand on veut insulter un une femme
gravement on la traite de [ __ ]
et quand on veut insulter un homme
gravement ou le traite de fils de [ __ ]
voilà est-ce que ça serait pas ça la
double peine a certes y'a un moment ce
sont toujours les femmes qui prennent
ceci dit c'est normal puisque les femmes
valent moins que les hommes
ah bah c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est ma
langue et le pouvoir d'une langue est
sans limite
je sais pas si vous savez par exemple
mais en france on nous a quand même
vendu pendant des décennies un suffrage
universel où les femmes n'avaient pas le
droit de vote et ça gênait personne
oui c'est le suffrage universel ah non
pas toi en revanche ni toi ni toi ni toi
ni toi ni tabac ni la moitié du pays en
fait non mais c'est quand même fou ceci
en même temps non c'est pas fou c'est
normal puisqu'on dit les droits de
l'homme
il ya un moment faut être cohérent ah
oui et alors à toutes celles qui me
disant couthouis noémie c'est pénible on
dit les droits de l'homme n'est pas les
droits humains parce que l'homme avec un
grand h ça veut dire humain est tu sais
que je réponds très bien mais alors
maintenant qu'il ya des droits des
femmes
ça veut dire quoi que les femmes ne sont
pas des humains et non c'est pas drôle
c'est chiant il ya comme un petit hiatus
d'autant que encore une fois le mot
sommes dans la déclaration de l'homme et
des droits de l'homme et du citoyen ne
doit rien au hasard mais bien à une
réelle volonté d'écarter juridiquement
les femmes du droit de vote
pour la petite histoire les rédacteurs
de la déclaration onusienne
1949 voulait mettre man rights et ce fut
la seule femme présente
eleanor roosevelt qui se bâtit pour
qu'on adopte human rights afin de
couvrir également les droits des femmes
mot vin expression que la france traduit
à tort par droits de l'homme accordant
fort généreusement un jour par an le 8
mars aux droits des femmes
merci la france oui enfin ne fait pas
les malins parce que ça c'est valable
dans toutes les langues est quasiment
dans toutes les langues les mots hommes
et les maux humains sont synonymes ou
équivalent en laissant donc aux mots aux
femmes et aux personnes qu'ils désignent
coucou la place de l'autre du subalterne
du pas humain voilà et pour vous prouver
à quel point nous pensons le sexisme
sans même s'en apercevoir
j'ai un petit jeu à vous proposer très
marrant il suffit de remplacer le mot
femme par le mot noir dans les
expressions de tous les jours car je
vous donne un petit exemple d'aller voir
c'est super drôle
les femmes ne savent pas conduire
qui n'a pas déjà dit ça les noirs ne
savent pas conduire un ça craque ça
passe pas pareil hein
un deuxième exemple juste pour le
plaisir les femmes sont moins forte en
maths que les hommes
tout le monde le sait les noirs sont
moins forts en maths que les blancs ah
là là ça pique un onze mais voilà alors
à vous maintenant les femmes sont
naturellement plus à l'aise avec le
travail domestique
alors on n'a pas envie de le dire un non
mais ne le dites pas à ces affreux mais
ça prouve bien qu'il ya un petit
problème quand même parce qu'avec femme
ça ne gêne personne
et puis alors j'imagine qu'on est très
nombreux et nombreuses ici avoir déjà
employé l'expression la journée de la
femme
moi je l' ai déjà fait en tout cas vous
imaginez si on disait la journée du noir
la journée du noir c'est cadeau c'est
pour moi et en plus ce qui est
formidable c'est que ça marche avec
toutes les généralités même positive
c'est à dire que s'il est raciste de
dire les noirs on sens du rythme et bien
il est sexiste de dire les femmes ont le
sens de l'organisation
voilà c'est sexiste et c'est quand notre
monde restera unique tant que nos mots
le seront par ce qu'on pense avec des
mots une langue sexistes qui maltraitent
les femmes créera un monde sexistes qui
maltraitent les femmes un monde machiste
et violent où les femmes sont
déconsidérés des classes et sous-payés
maltraités violente et sans espoirs
d'égalité
aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas les outils
pour changer le monde parce que nous
n'avons pas les mots pour le penser
autrement égalitaire et juste
le combat pour l'égalité doit commencer
par la langue et comme le disait qui
donc
simone de beauvoir d'utah s'éveille
g.bogaert laquelle non comme c'est
simone de beauvoir en 78 à propos de
l'entrée du mot sexisme dans le
dictionnaire
on pensera peut-être que c'est une
conquête mineurs et on aura tort car
nommé s'est dévoilée est dévoilé c'est
déjà agir donc ce que je vous propose
c'est que là ici maintenant
là tout de suite on commence à changer
le monde en changeant les mots et il ya
plein de trucs super simple à faire
enfin en tout cas pour mes compatriotes
et je suis sûr dans d'autres langues
on peut déjà commencer par employé des
mots épicène et des tournures inclusive
c'est à dire éviter par exemple salut
les gars ou salut à tous en début de
mails quand il y a deux mecs sur 32
destinataire par exemple on peut aussi
milité pour remplacer le masculin
l'emportent par des règles d'accord qui
ont été en usage pendant des siècles en
france avant que l'académie ne s'en mêle
comme la règle de majorité vous 1000
femmes et un homme est belle ou alors
vous mille hommes et une femme est beau
nom mais simple la majorité le plus
grand nombre l'emportent
ou alors comme la règle de proximité un
homme et une femme sont belles une femme
et un homme sont beaux voiliers le plus
proche
le nom le plus proche des adjectifs
l'emportent simple basique on pourra
aussi évidemment militer pour l'emploi
de l'expression droits de la personne
humaine ou droits humains comme au
québec francophone plutôt que droits de
l'homme s'il vous plaît est ce que j'ai
une tête d'homme franchement non mais
vous auriez pu rire plus fort quand même
parce que franchement j'ai pas une tête
d'homme battu
non mais c'est vrai on pourrait aussi en
france je souhaiterais qu'on milite pour
une réforme de la devise républicaine
française liberté égalité fraternité qui
exclut donc la moitié du pays bah oui
fraternité ça vient deux frères sororité
ça vient de soeur est le mot qui parle
des frères et des soeurs ces solidarités
nous moi je milite pour une devise dont
le troisième mot ne contredit pas le
deuxième une devise inclusive une devise
juste et humaine
liberté égalité solidarité et je suis
sûr que ça serait un excellent point
d'entrée pour sensibiliser les jeunes et
les enfants aux questions d'égalité un
autre monde
en d'autres mots je suis certaine qu'on
peut y arriver
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]